PRESIDENT BIDEN SET TO ANNOUNCE
A MAJOR OPERATION AGAINST
TERRORISTS IN AFGHANISTAN THAT
INVOLVES AN AL QAEDA OPERATIVE,
SOME BRAND-NEW INFORMATION, WHAT
DO YOU KNOW?
>> WE CAN CONFIRM FROM TWO
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES THAT
AL QAEDA LEADER HAS BEEN KILLED
BY A CIA DRONE STRIKE IN
AFGHANISTAN OVER THE WEEKEND,
AND THAT IS WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
WILL ANNOUNCE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT AT 7:30
EASTERN TIME.
YOU WILL REMEMBER HE WAS THE
DEPUTY UNDER USAMA BIN LADEN ON
9/11.
HE IS ONE OF THE MOST WANTED
TERRORIST AND HAS BEEN FOR A
LONG TIME.
HERE IS THE FBI SHEET ON HIM, HE
TOOK OVER THE LEADERSHIP AFTER
THE DEATH OF BIN LADEN AND IS
CONSIDERED TO BE AT ONE POINT
POSSIBLY DEAD, BUT JUST A REPORT
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS SO
THAT HE COULD BE OPERATING IN
AFGHANISTAN COMMUNICATING
TERRORISTS.
IF THIS IS AGAIN TO INTELLIGENCE
SOURCES SAYING THAT THIS IS A
BIG COUNTERTERRORISM WIN FOR THE
U.S.
KILLED IN THIS DRONE STRIKE.
THIS COMES AS AL QAEDA, WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT TERRORISM A LOT, WE
TALKED ABOUT ISIS FOR A LONG
TIME, BUT AL QAEDA WAS MAKING A
RESURGENCE AND IS MAKING A
RESURGENCE IN THE MIDDLE EAST
CONSIDERED TO BE VERY DANGEROUS
STILL AND THIS IS A MAJOR, MAJOR
DEBT.
THE NEXT IN COMMAND IS A GUY
NAMED -- LONGTIME AL QAEDA
LEADER AND VETERAN, SECOND IN
COMMAND ASSUMED HE WOULD TAKE
CONTROL OF THE ORGANIZATION, WE
WILL HEAR MORE DETAILS AS WE GET
THEM FROM THE CIA DRONE STRIKE
OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> Kennedy: SO WAS THIS A
SPONTANEOUS OR AN OPERATION LIKE
WITH USAMA BIN LADEN?
>> Bret: IT WAS A DRONE STRIKE
WITH ACTIVE INTEL.
THEY HAD INTELLIGENCE OR WE ARE
BEING TOLD THAT HE WAS AT A
CERTAIN RESIDENCE OUTSIDE OF
KABBUL.
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THE U.S.
HAD BEEN OPERATING THERE FOR A
LONG TIME IS THIS LEADER, THEY
ACTED ON AN INTELLIGENCE AND WE
ARE TOLD THAT IT WAS A DRONE
STRIKE.
WE DON'T KNOW THE CONFIRMATION
AND WHAT LED TO THEIR
CONFIDENCE, BUT AGAIN, YOU WILL
HEAR A MOMENT TONIGHT THAT WILL
BE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BIN LADEN
MOMENTS, BECAUSE HE WILL GIVE A
SPEECH WE ARE TOLD THAT DEALS
WITH THE FIGHT AGAINST TERRORISM
THAT HAS BEEN ONGOING EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT
IT A LOT.
YOU SEE ON THE SCREEN THERE HAD
BEEN A LEADER, SPIRITUAL LEADER
AND ALSO SOMEONE WHO WAS FOR
LAMENTING TERRORISM IN DIFFERENT
GROUPS AROUND THE WORLD, THIS IS
A HUGE, HUGE WIN FOR THE U.S.
AND WE EXPECT TO HEAR THAT AND
WHERE OVER THE FIGHT GOES FROM
HERE ARE TAKING OUT OTHER
TERRORISTS.
>> Katie: HEY, GOOD TO SEE YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR BRING IN THE
NEWS TO US, SO THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ARGUED AFTER THE
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN, THE
ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY WHICH DID
NOT GO WELL THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
THE CAPABILITY WITH HORIZON
DRONE STRIKES AND CIA
INTELLIGENCE TO GO AFTER
TERRORISM IN AFGHANISTAN, CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
WITH THAT BACKDROP AND GIVEN THE
STRIKE THAT WE WILL HEAR MORE
ABOUT FROM THE PRESIDENT
TONIGHT?
>> Bret: THAT IS A GREAT
POINT, THIS WILL BACK UP SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT CRITICS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAD THAT
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE THESE EYES
TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP ON LEADS
ON THE GROUND, IF EVERYTHING WE
ARE HEARING IS ACCURATE AND WE
BELIEVE IT TO BE TRUE, THEY HAD
SOME ACTIVE INTELLIGENCE FROM
PEOPLE ON THE GROUNDS THAT WERE
WORKING WITH AND THAT LED TO
THIS RESIDENCE AND THAT LED TO
THE CIA DRONE STRIKE, SO THAT
OVER THE HORIZON STRIKE
CAPABILITY WAS THERE DESPITE THE
CONCERNS STILL ABOUT WHERE
AFGHANISTAN IS WITH THE TALIBAN
AND WITHOUT THE GUIDANCE OF U.S.
FORCES OVER THE HORIZON.
>> Kennedy: JESSE?
>> Jesse: A GREAT WIN FOR THE
UNITED STATES AND A CLEAR
VICTORY OVER TERRORISM,
POLITICALLY FOR THE PRESIDENT WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT IN THE LETTER
A BLOCK HOW THE ADMINISTRATION
AND SOME OF THE MEDIA HAVE BEEN
FRAMING THIS AS A RESURGENCE OF
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY AND A FEW
THINGS ABOUT TO BE PASSED IN
CONGRESS AND NOW THIS BIG STRIKE
ANNOUNCEMENT TONIGHT, DO YOU
THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO LOOK TO CAPITALIZE ON
THIS MOMENTUM INTO AUGUST AFTER
BEING DOWN FOR QUITE SOME TIME
ON THE MAT?
>> Bret: 100%, JESSE, YOU
CAN'T TAKE AWAY THAT THIS HAS
BEEN A COUPLE OF GOOD WEEKS FOR
THE PRESIDENT WHO HAS BEEN --
WE HAVE NOT SEEN TOO MUCH OF,
BEHIND THE SCENES WITH COVID,
BUT HE IS AT LEAST ON THE
PRECIPICE OF A COUPLE OF
LEGISLATIVE WINS.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY ALL LINE
UP, BUT IT SEEMS LIKE IT IS AN
OBVIOUSLY HAS THE CHIPS BILL,
NOW AT THIS ANNOUNCEMENT AGAIN,
IT WILL BE A POSITIVE --
YOU CAN'T LOOK AT IT ANY OTHER
WAY.
AND IT WILL NOT TAKE AWAY FROM
THE HORRIBLE NATURE IN WHICH WE
GOT OUT OF AFGHANISTAN, BUT IT
WILL ENABLE THEM TO MAKE THE
CASE THAT THEY ARE STILL
FIGHTING TERRORISTS AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> Greg: I KNOW THE ANSWER
WILL PROBABLY BE I DON'T KNOW,
BUT I WILL ASK ANYWAY, THEY DO
SAY NO CASUALTIES, THIS IS A BIG
STRIKE, BUT IT IS ALWAYS HARD TO
BELIEVE TO HEAR THAT WHEN THEY
SAY THAT IT IS A RESIDENCE AND
WHEN THEY ARE WEIGHING THE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE, HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS NO
CASUALTIES?
>> Bret: WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
ONE CASUALTY, BUT WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE OTHER DETAILS AND WE
ARE JUST GETTING PIECES OF THIS
TO GET THAT CONFIRMATION ABOUT
WHO IT WAS WAS WHAT WE WERE
TRYING TO DO, BUT YOU ARE RIGHT.
ANY OF THESE DRONE STRIKES CAN
BE MESSY.
THEIR PRECISION TO THE TARGETS,
BUT YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IS IN OR
AROUND THE TARGET, SO HOPEFULLY
WE WILL GET SOME MORE
INFORMATION TONIGHT.
>> Jessica: HEY, THANKS FOR
JOINING US I WAS CURIOUS IF YOU
THOUGHT THAT THIS WOULD USHER IN
A NEW ERA OR MULTIPLE NEW CYCLES
OF TALKING ABOUT ISLAMIC
TERRORISM AGAIN.
IT FEELS LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT IT
A BIT WITH THE WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN BUT BEFORE THAT IT
WAS YEARS AND YEARS BEFORE IT
WAS REALLY A FOCUS, DO YOU THINK
THAT THAT CHANGES THE LANDSCAPE?
>> Bret: I DO.
I THINK THAT IT GETS BACK INTO
PEOPLE'S MINDS ABOUT WHERE WE
WERE IN HUNTING THESE PEOPLE
DOWN AFTER 9/11.
THINK ABOUT HOW MANY, I WAS AT
THE PENTAGON AT THAT TIME OVER
THOSE YEARS AS THE HUNT FOR
BIN LADEN WAS CONTINUING, AND
THERE WAS A HUNT BACK THEN ABOUT
ALL OF THE QUESTIONS WHERE HE
COULD BE IN THE MOUNTAINS
BETWEEN AFGHANISTAN AND PAKISTAN
AND HERE IS A SUCCESSFUL STRIKE
RIGHT OUTSIDE.
AND I THINK THAT IT WILL BRING
TO THE FOREFRONT, THE THING THAT
IS NOT IN THE FRONT OF PEOPLE'S
MINDS BECAUSE WE HAVE
FORTUNATELY NOT HAD A BIG
TERRORIST ATTACK HERE IN A LONG
TIME.
THEY'RE BEEN INSPIRED TO TAX,
BUT AL QAEDA IS STILL OUT THERE
AND I THINK THAT WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT THE PRESIDENT
TALKS ABOUT.